foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Great Torrington in the south
west corner of England
uh we're here today to celebrate sister
nevadita's birthday
sister never did spent much of her life
in India where she is revered as an
educationalist and campaigner for
India's Freedom Movement
her involvement with India came about
after a meeting with Swami Vivekananda
in London in 1895. after which she
traveled to Calcutta
she was given the name nivedita meaning
dedicated to God
and opened a girl's school in 1898
her intention was to educate girls who
were at the time deprived of even the
most basic education
she is also noted for nursing the poor
during the plague epidemic in Calcutta
in 1899
as well as having close association with
the ramakrishna mission
until later when she became an active
contribution in the field of Indian
Nationalism
we're very happy to say that before
sister nevadita went to India she lived
in great Torrington here in North Devon
and she was born Margaret Noble
so it's a great celebration I hope you
all enjoy
um and join with us in in this little
event
thank you everybody
foreign